الى موضوع اا مجلس النواب والشيوخ
الامريكيين اللذين وفقا على ميزانيه
الدفاع السنويه بقيمه
858 مليار دولار وقلب لجنتي القوات
المسلحه في المجلسين ان المشرعين وافقوا
ايضا على مساعدات الامنيه لاوكرانيا بقيمه
800 مليون دولار العام المقبل اضافه
لتزويد تايوان بمساعده امنيه بقيمه
مليارات الدولارات على مدى الاعوام
القادمه من جانبها فقط وزاره الخارجيه
الامريكيه على صفقه تزويد تايوان بمعداتهم
وقطع غيار للطائرات بقيمه 330 مليون دولار
بالاضافه الى مساعدات اخرى بقيمتي ثمانيه
وتسعين مليون دولار
الخطوه الامريكيه وقالت في قالت وزاره
الدفاع في بيان ان البيعه المقترح من قبل
الولايات المتحده لقطع غيار الطائرات
سيساعد عمليات سلاح الجوي التايوانيه في
مواجهه زياده الانشطه العسكريه للصين
وزير الدفاع الامريكي لويدد الصين بانها
تزعزع لاستقرار في منطقه المحيطين الهندي
الاسترالي ريتشارد في واشنطن ان بلاده
ودعت اليابان الى انضمام الى ما سماهم
مبادرات تتعلق بالتموضع قوات بلاده في
استراليا
انتم شروق
اسراب القارفات والمقاتلات والتناوب
المستقبليه لقدرات البحريه والجيش
الامريكيين وسنعزز تعاونا لوجستي ونسعى
الى تكامل منشاتنا الدفاعيه وقررنا ايضا
دعوه اليابان الى الانخراط في مبادرات
تتعلق بث موضوعنا في استراليا ان تصرفات
الصيني الخطيره في جميع انحاء منطقه
المحيطين الهادي والهندي بما في ذلك حول
الصين الجنوبيه الشرقيه تهدد السلام
والاستقرار الاقليميه